نتذكر جميعا الفتره الاولى التي تم
انتخابك فيها رئيسا للوزراء الفتره اللي
قضيت فيها 22 عاما
تقريبا
استطعت فيها دكتور مهاتير ان تحول ماليزيا
من حقل الكبير للمطاط من دوله زراعيه الى
واحده من اهم الدول الاسيويه اقتصاديا
ممكن تعطينا الوصفه
كيف الطريقه ما هي الطريقه التي تعاملت
بها حتى نجحت بكل هذه السنوات
لا انفسه في الفتره الاولى التي اصبحت
فيها رئيس وزراء كان حزبي قويا جدا كانت
له سلطه تامه على البرلمان كنت قادرا بسبب
ذلك على القيام بامور كثيره من ضمنها
تحويل ماليزيا من دوله زراعيه الى دوله
صناعيه
لكن وكان القرار كان قرارا سياسيا فقط انا
اريد ان توضح لي اكثر كيف نج في تحويل
ماليزيا لواحده من اكبر اقتصادات اسيا ان
تتحول من دوله زراعيه الى واحده من اكبر
اقتصادات اسيا الوصفه الطريقه
اساسا بسبب قوه الحكومه التي كانت تسندها
اغلبيه مريحه لذلك كنا قادرين على اتخاذ
القرارات وكان البرلمان يمنحها الدعم
الكامل بسبب ان الناس في ماليزيا كانوا
بحاجه الى العمل وهو ما لا يتوفر بما يكفي
في دوله تعتمد على الزراعه ولذلك قررنا
اطلاق الصناعات لان ذلك يسمح للكثيرين
بالعمل وهو ما وفر الدعم لسياستنا من قبل
الناس لانهم يستفيدون من تحويل البلاد من
دوله زراعيه الى دوله صناعيه
او ما زالت صالحه لماليزيا او لاي دوله
اخرى ان يكون هناك اتفاق سياسي على تطوير
المجتمع
صالحه غالبيه الدول التي تعتمد على
الزراعه لا يمكنها ان تصبح ثريا لو تتجه
نحو الصناعه فانها ستوفر الكثير من الفرص
والعمل والوظائف لشعوبها التي ستصبح اثرى
ولذلك نرى دائما ان الدول الصناعيه اكثر
ثراء من الدول الزراعيه